foreign
[Music]
let's get this show on the road welcome
everybody to another speedrun game
I was away for a week so once again my
apologies for
the uh the delay
in the next video but now the video
should be coming out pretty regularly
and I'll be diversifying my content uh
this coming month as well so we're
playing White against very strong player
2198 this is the the strongest opponent
that we Face to date and let's see how
the elephant fares against a serious
player of a high caliber I think there's
there's an idea that the elephant is
sort of only good at beginner to
intermediate level and I vehemently
disagree with that I think it's a
tremendously dangerous weapon all the
way to GM level
and E6 is one of the many sort of I
wouldn't even call it a second rate move
but it's definitely one tier behind the
two main moves which are D5 and Knight
F6 and E6 is kind of a flexible move
um and which black can play several
different ways the traditional response
here is D5 and for black to be okay with
this
for black to play this he has to be okay
with allowing E5 which transposes into
an advanced French but since my
recommendation against the French is not
to play the advance and I've never
really played it uh myself most of the
time Sicilian players with black uh even
if they don't play the French are kind
of bluffing light into playing E5 and
oftentimes neither side really knows
what to do in that situation but the
more alepp and esque of playing this
line is actually to take on Z5 after
which black is at sort of an early
Crossroads you can transpose back into
uh the 2d5 variation if you take with a
queen
or you can kind of keep the spirit of
the E6 line by Taking Back width upon
and you can already see the kind of
workings of of an iqp structure because
if black takes back with a pawn and then
at some point white plays Pawn take C5
black recaptures and then black will
have an isolated Pawn on D5 and that is
the classic isolated Queen pun structure
and that is exactly what is going to
happen now one good thing about the
placement of the Pawn on C3 is that in
this in this situation where we take on
C5 and black takes back that C3 Pawn
will have the effect of slowing down uh
the D5 pawn and and controlling the
square in front of it which I've talked
about very frequently as one of the most
important things to do when you're
fighting against the isolated Queen Pawn
you can put a knight on the Square in
front of it but more importantly is to
kind of is to control the square it's
more important to control a square than
to put a piece on that square those are
two different things
but Pawn takes C5 immediately is decent
but it's not the best way to squeeze the
most out of this position what we would
want to do in an ideal scenario and this
rule this concept also exists in
openings like the Queen's Gambit which
is that you want to wait for black to
move the dark squirt Bishop first then
and only then do you take on C5 because
that essentially makes black lose a
Tempo black plays Bishop B7 and then
that Bishop again takes the pawn on C5
we've garnered a Tempo that we can use
to develop our pieces and so as far as I
remember the best move and the most
commonly recommended move for white is
Bishop B5 check just developing our
Bishop with Tempo and asking black
another
difficult question black is again at a
Crossroads here Bishop D7 is is a move
but generally trades are good for the
side that fights the iqp because the
fewer pieces you have the harder it is
to to essentially keep that honor to
control Knight C6 is the more topical
response and now we kind of follow the
rule we don't take on C5 instead we
develop our pieces and wait for a more
opportune moment uh to take that pawn
the moment black develops his Bishop
that would be a very good time to
consider taking on C5
okay and so far we're playing
pretty standard moves this is still well
known Theory
and black has multiple ways that they
can they can develop their pieces there
we go there's Bishop D6 now what's funny
is that we we can delay the move to e
take C5 one more move like we can Castle
here and it's not like black has any
good way of resolving the tension in the
center like black cat punished us for
avoiding D take C5 for one more move but
I want to kind of stick to a more
traditional way of playing and
traditionally you want to take on C5 the
moment the black develops their Bishop
Okay so Bishop takes C5 is going to
follow and we've earned a Tempo because
black has made an extra move with with
his Bishop so now we can Castle get our
King out of the center
and the next big question is going to be
where is our opponent going to develop
his Knight there's 97 and there's Knight
F6 and
they lead broadly speaking to similar
positions but our development is going
to be based on where black positions his
Knight because in response to Knight F6
I I like the look of playing Bishop G5
and kind of pinning that Knight and
making it hard for black to move the way
that he wants to but if black develops
the Knight to E7 then Bishop G5 makes a
little bit less sense because that would
walk right into the move F6 and F6 in
this particular position isn't such a
weakening move it's not something that
we would want to pay with uh several
Tempe for like we wouldn't want to go
Bishop G5 and then he do sap6 and go
back so black chooses the the
traditional developing move Knight F6
and here
there are several important ideas that
you should be aware of when you're
fighting uh the iqp in particular we
should have a general sense of where
we're putting the rest of our minor
pieces the move I don't like as well
actually it's interesting what we this
check on E1 I think a lot of people
would be very tempted to give but then
black can simply cover with the bishop
and the F2 Pawn is a major problem in
these positions because the queen can
easily come out to B6 there are even
some tactics or black takes on F2 and
then Forks the king and Bishop so we
actually would want to keep our Rook on
F1 in order to solidify the F2 pawn and
make sure that there are no tactical
Shenanigans connected with Queen B6 or
Knight E4 uh or even Bishop takes F2
check so
there's two main questions here the
first is where to position this bishop
we've kind of been deciding on G5 the
second is what to do with our Knight and
typically
um if you're at all familiar with iqp
structures you know that the knight in
these situations often travels to B3
hits the bishop and positions itself on
a square where it can blockade the
square in front of the pawn there really
aren't any other options for the
development of our Knight the real
decision we have to make is what order
do we develop our pieces in but I like
the look of starting with Bishop G5
because it restricts the Knight it
immediately sets up a pin
and of course the drawback of playing
Knight B to D2 first is that the bishop
would be temporarily blocked in by the
Knight so this just seems like a more
harmonious way of developing Bishop E6
instantly follows
I don't love the look of this move black
is delaying castling and giving us some
additional options here like we could
throw in the immediate Knight T4 and put
some pressure on Black's minor pieces
but I really don't want to make too many
of these adventurous moves I want to
play in a more traditional fashion to
really highlight uh the techniques that
we have of fighting against the iqp a
white is slightly better here not
because black has an iqp like if you if
you watch my speedrun videos you know
that the isolated Queen Pawn structure
is one in which you can't make any
categorical assertions about who is
better it all depends on the placement
of the other pieces there are situations
where the iqp is a great asset and there
are situations where it's a tremendous
weakness and I think that this situation
resembles the latter more than it does
the former just because Black's piece
activity is not uh not all that
impressive like black is pinned along
this diagonal the bishop on E6 is kind
of a passive Observer and is just sort
of tied down to the pawn and most
importantly as we play Knight B3 we've
been able to reach and Achieve complete
control of the square in front of the
pawn which means that the iqp is no
longer a moving Target
um and and it's going to saddle black
uh we're really likely for the rest of
the game at least for the rest of the
time that it exists on D5 so now we
enter a stage where we need to make sort
of marginal improving moves we need to
build up our advantage uh and eventually
something is going to give in sort of
the ideal scenario but we have to be
careful about like what exactly we do
and if you're not familiar with this
structure then it can be hard to
generate helpful moves you might look at
this and say well I developed all my
pieces what do I do now and and there
are some moves that that you really want
to avoid like for example I think some
people might want to go Queen to D2 here
and connect the Rooks but Queen D2
tactically runs into the response Knight
to E4 and that leads to some undesirable
traits for white it leads to undesirable
tactics in general I think the kind of
low-hanging fruit that we should start
with is actually to position a knight on
D4 and as I mentioned earlier it's more
important to control the square in front
of the pawn than it is to actually put a
piece on that square but I'm not trying
to suggest that put a piece on it is
somehow a bad idea I really like the
look of Knight C4 because that Knight is
sort of on an Ideal Square it's putting
some pressure on Black's minor pieces
and it's just a relatively inoffensive
move that we could play without thinking
too much about the consequences so
we can go Knight ft4 we can go Knight
bd4 a lot of these minor points are are
less important than I think a lot of
people make them out to be I think it's
more natural to play Knight B to D4 just
to keep this other Knight on the king's
side
um where it controls you know some some
key squares and lends a little bit
another layer of support to whites King
okay so Knight B to D4 and already we're
asking black some more straightforward
questions we're threatening to win a
pawn like obviously we're threatening to
take twice on C6
if black plays Knight takes D4 which is
quite likely then we recapture with our
Knight
an already black black is a little bit
of trouble there like it's it's hard to
make a move if you're playing Black
because the last thing you want to do is
is move your queen out of d8 then we
would play Bishop takes F6 and
completely spoil the pawn structure
Bishop D7 is a good move that's a good
move that's a 2100 move just sort of
keeping the tension and protecting this
Knight so what do we do now well black
is threatening to play Knight takes D4
which again leads to unpleasant tactical
complications we run the risk of losing
a piece in that position because of
course if you play Bishop takes D7 there
then black will capture on F3 and then
recapture on D7 with an extra piece so
we want to avoid those types of
complications when possible we should
also keep in mind that you can sometimes
successfully change the pawn structure
or change the nature of your advantage
from an iqp to something more Dynamic
and I think this is a very instructive
situation in which we can do just that
my instinct is actually to make a move
that
I would venture to say is unnatural to
the vast majority of people and this is
a move that's probably on your radar but
you might think that it's bad because it
fixes the problem of Black's iqp and it
seems to give away our biggest asset but
the benefit of this move I think is that
it transforms our advantage from a
strictly positional one to an actual
initiative to a situation where our
Superior peace activity is what gives us
the biggest uh is what gives us our
advantage rather than the presence of a
long-term weakness
and that is the move Bishop takes C6
so what are the minuses of this move
well there are two big ones we're giving
away the bishop pair that's number one
but more importantly we're allowing B
take C6 after which the D5 Pawn is no
longer isolated
and B takes C6 leads to the hanging Pawn
structure which perhaps some of you have
heard of and the hanging pod structure
is characterized by the presence of
Pawns on the C and D file that are
themselves
removed from any other Pawn so there's
no b-pawn and there's no E Pawn so you
kind of have this self-sufficient Pond
Island on C6 and D5 and those are called
uh hanging pods and the way that you
should kind of think about hanging pawns
is that the isolated Pawn has shifted
from the D file to the C file the
product C6 is now essentially an
isolated Pawn even though it has a
neighboring Pawn on Z5 the pawn on Z5
can't go backwards and defend C6 so for
all intents and purposes the biggest
weakness uh in the hanging Pawn
structure is in this position C6 and we
can attack that one very
straightforwardly by positioning our
Knight on E5 but 95 also contains a
couple of other important positional
threats first of all we're threatening
to take the pawn on C6 but most
importantly we're also threatening to
take on D7 and then to take on F6 and
completely ruin Black's kingside Pawn
structure we can also start with Bishop
takes F6 because the queen can't
recapture it's defending the bishop so
there are many many threats that we are
creating by positioning our knights in
the way that we do
and uh black is struggling here to keep
all of the bases covered of course
Bishop takes D4 as possible but then we
get a huge Advantage we can even
recapture with the pawn
and if you just look at the way that our
minor pieces are positioned there
black is borderline positionally lost in
case he gives away the dark squared
Bishop
so it's it's hard to like
you know quantify exactly why white is
better in this position you just have to
kind of think of it as a very unpleasant
position for black to play uh because
there are a lot of things that he has to
keep protective blacks pieces are
passive and our minor pieces are
essentially all on optimal squares
so I think black does have a way to beat
back White's initiative but it would
require finding a lot of very accurate
moves
uh so so I don't think that Bishop C6 is
likely to be the engine's recommendation
if the engine often likes to drop the
bishop back in these types of situations
but you know given that we have a big
initiative here and this is more my
style I find this hard to resist
okay a lot of tactics here hanging in
the air as well let's see what our
opponent ends up choosing the fact that
he's thinking for this long is a pretty
encouraging sign
black has many ways that that they can
try to fight uh this initiative yeah
Queen E8 is actually a a pretty smart
move it's being proposed in the chat
because this unpins the queen and
attacks the 995 and we'll talk about it
after the game black plays the move that
I was expecting which is C5 and this is
a very straightforward move but this
move fails tactically if I've calculated
this correctly to a beautiful sequence
and I saw this when I played Bishop
takes C6 this was one of the things that
we kind of had to calculate when making
that move so when you look at this
position your instinct is probably to
move the Knight away from D4 but that's
not the only thing available to us if if
you listen carefully to what I just said
you should know that a possibility here
is to play Bishop takes F6 and queen
takes F6 is still impossible Knight
takes D7 also comes with a fork so after
Bishop takes F6 G takes F6 you know at a
minimum we could just just take the
bishop on D7 and then move this Knight
away and we could claim that we're
slightly better because
Black's Pawn structure on the king side
is damaged but that also doesn't tell
the whole story if we Waltz into that
position black had tucked the king away
on h8 and actually use the G file to his
advantage and generate attacking chances
against our own kick but I actually
think that there is a specific tactical
sequence here that leads to
very unpleasant consequence for black
although
I actually need a little more time here
it's a small detail there that I missed
hmm wow
yeah there's a crazy line my idea was
like Bishop takes F6 GF Knight C6
Bishop takes C6 Knight takes C6 and then
we have this tactic where we take on D5
and Sack the queen temporarily and then
give a fork on E7 I'll have to show all
of this after the game it's just
impossible to to explain it verbally
so there is one small problem with that
idea and it's actually more than a small
problem it might mean we have to deviate
from the path that I had intended okay
so I actually think there is an issue
with
with my uh with my initial idea so in
that case I think we have to resort to
the mo the more straightforward path
here which is which is to take on F6
take on D7 and then try to claim a small
Advantage based on Black's weak hanging
pawns and and the wiking side
unfortunately I think we have to go for
it Bishop takes F6
and we have to play a little bit faster
here given our time situation
um okay let's see what our opponent does
here I mean queen F6 loses on the spot
I'm not sure what what black is thinking
about yeah GF so unfortunately the move
Knight C6 here actually fails tactically
to Bishop C6 Knight C6 and then this
move Queen E8 which is like Ultra
Advanced tactics and I'll show this in
Greater depth after the game but this is
the kind of thing you just kind of
either you see it or you don't
um and and as I mentioned before a lot
of top level chess really boils down to
these tactical details that you have to
spot and it's not you know they just
exist it's not like you can arrive at
them with logical reasoning you just
have to spot them
um and now
we have to move our Knight but we have
to figure out where that Knight belongs
Knight F3 I don't like because then the
Knight will be restricted by the F6 Pawn
I actually like the look of Knight to C2
or even Knight to E2 but we're gonna
settle on Knight to C2 because it keeps
the diagonal open for the queen and the
reason I like Knight C2 the most is
because the Knight can reroute to E3 and
continue harassing the D5 Pawn which is
one of Black's main weaknesses here as
is the F6 Pawn so I still think that
white is better it's not as big of an
advantage as I had hoped for but really
only one side is having fun now what are
some moves that we could make uh to
improve our position well an easy move
is Queen F3 which continues to Target
the D5 Pawn but also sets this it sets
our sights on the F6 Pawn and that's a
particularly good response to a move
like King age eight because we don't
want to leave our thing unattended
especially given the fact that at some
later Point black and play C4 and open
up The Bishop's diagonal so Queen F3 is
a multi-purpose movement it attacks F6
and it defends G2 and it essentially
nips any g-file pressure in the bud
now the move I think a lot of people
would play here with black is D4 I think
people and across really all rating
ranges would be tempted by this move but
remember that in the middle game a
double uh a past Pawn is a double-sided
thing like on the one hand that pawn
looks dangerous on the other hand it's
still going to be isolated after the
trade on D4 and we have enough pieces to
where we can
successfully restrain that pawn and then
start attacking it so for instance one
easy way to fight the move d4 would be
to take on D4 and then to still play the
move Queen to F3 attack the F6 pawn and
gain a Tempo that we could use to bring
our Rook into the game and at that point
the D4 Pawn will be in Dire Straits I
think black will have a very hard time
to defend it Okay so
again a situation in which it's kind of
hard for black to find a a helpful move
maybe Rook a to d8 should be considered
something slow but Queen F5 would be a
good example of like an impulsive move
that turns out to be a blunder because
it walks right into the fork right
Knight E3 hits the queen and hits the
pawn
and of course we could grab that pawn
and support the Knight with C4 if
necessary well I like positions where
both sides have only one minor piece I
think they're quite instructive
and these positions are good for like
illustrating kind of important strategic
and positional ideas
I I wouldn't necessarily call this a
case of like good night against Bad
Bishop because box Bishop isn't terrible
Black's Bishop could be activated with
C4
but the bigger problem in Black's
position is just all of the pawn
weaknesses and the fact that the king is
so flimsy okay so Rook d8 played Black
puts the other Rook on Zia which
surprises me a little bit now the king
feels a little bit more even more
uncomfortable
and I would start with Queen F3 here
um we could also start with Knight to E3
but this move makes I think less sense
now that it doesn't attack the D5 Pawn
so I think Queen F3 is the more accurate
way to start because at the very least
it forces black to contend with the the
big threat of Queen takes F6
which makes the king even weaker okay
so one idea that our opponent might have
is just to throw caution to the win and
play D4 here anyway and in the event
that that happens after C takes d4c
takes D4 I would be seriously
considering the prospect of not taking
on F6 because that leads to tremendous
complications it allows Black's d-pawn
to run amok with D3 I still think that
position is good for white I still think
that pawn is not as dangerous as it may
appear given all of our pieces and how
active they are but after D4 we could
also consider the simple Rook HD1 either
before or after a c takes D4 so I think
D4 is is really not not a big concern
okay Queen D6 oh now that is a natural
move because it protects F6 but the
moment I see this move I immediately
think well now the Knight can reach F5
with Tempo so Knight E3 becomes even
more attempting than it was
and if we're concerned about D4 we could
definitely start with the move Rook 881
I think both moves are good I think Rook
81 is the more measured Russian
Schoolboy or virtual Killers Brio pieces
into the green and later down the line
that Rook could actually lift itself
over to the king side via D3 so Rook ad1
isn't just a defensive move it's also an
attack but Knight E3 is super juicy
because Knight F5 is a huge threat it's
a massive threat and it's a massive
threat because it can be accompanied by
Queen G4 Queen G7 so that literally
could lead to Checkmate really really
quickly my guess is that in response the
93 black is going to go King h8 but I
don't see any reason why throwing this
pair of Moves In is is going to be bad
for us like I don't see a Universe in
which that's the case
so we'll start with that E3 Bishop C7
okay so that's a one move threat that's
not scary I think the simplest way to
defend against it is G3 a couple of
things to avoid here we don't want to
give an empty check on G4 because that
would only help black and the reason
that would help black is because black
wants to play King h8 anyway right King
h8 is is a move that favors black
because it puts the game in a safer
Square so here we want to keep the
tension with G3 and and definitely we
don't want to trade Queens like maybe I
could find a Russian GM who would want
to go Queen G3 check but to me the
presence of Queens
squarely favors white because obviously
because of the disparity in King's
safety and the fact that our Queen is
tremendously active here
so G3 is kind of a no-brainer I'm
expecting King h8 and in response to
that we're gonna play Rook 81 and apply
even more pressure on D5 at that point
black will have to play D4 and at that
point I think we could go for material
gains there's just no way that black
will be able to keep all his bases
covered
okay Queen E6
yeah that move is I guess an alternate
way to defend or at least to take the
sting out of Knight F5
and here I think we should operate by
the same principle of not rushing into
um not rushing into a move that gives us
uh that makes us feel good like Knight
F5 but rather bringing all the toys to
the party because when we actually do go
for the kill all of our pieces will be
involved and it's much likelier that our
attack is actually going to succeed and
in the spirit of that we can do two
things we can play Rook fte1 or we can
play the more straightforward Rook 8 D1
the cool thing about Rook F to E1 is
that it creates a beautiful tactical
threat and as you guys probably know by
now I find these things very hard to
resist so
um
Rook ft so Rook fe1 I think black might
be able to go Bishop E5
and that is not necessarily A Move that
we want to allow because if we allow
Bishop E5 then after D4 it's going to be
hard for us to Target that pawn so as
much as I would like to show off
tactically I feel like it's a better
idea
to just play the mundane Rook 8 to D1
not that there aren't tactics here like
if black plays D4 if you're watching on
YouTube like you should pause the video
and figure out what we think our
response is going to be to D4
and the moment D4 is played the first
thing you should notice is that the
queen now makes contacts with the Rook
on A8 and those types of small tactical
observations are incredibly important
and people who don't make those
observations often miss important
tactical opportunities that otherwise
are quite easy to see this is another
thing right Queen E4 well what's the
drawback of this move once you ask
yourself that question you immediately
see that F6 is unprotected
we can't trade on e4 and if we were in
more severe time pressure trading on e4
and getting a big advantage in the end
game would not be half bad idea but I
really don't see a single reason why we
can't just take on F6
especially because the queen 94 might
seem like it's a big strength but it's
actually incredibly vulnerable like the
moment we play Rook F to E1 we're
already going to be threatening massive
discovered attacks against the queen
Black's position is essentially just
collapsing on all sides we're already up
upon the pawn on D5 is likely to fall as
well the Knight is threatening to jump
into F5 with unstoppable mate threats
something's going to give here and we
should remember not to just look for
mates we should remember also to look
for Quiet Moves that just win a bunch of
material
and those kinds of moves can be pretty
easy to miss Rook D6
okay
so tactics are there any tactics here
I don't see anything overly appealing
off the top of my head some of you might
be tempted by Knight takes D5 but
unfortunately The Rook can just take the
Knight right Rook takes F6 is not forced
I think the simpler approach is just to
drop the queen back to G5 and create a
fork against the king in the D5 pawn and
just snag another Pawn
and at that point we'll be up two pawns
and we can start trading off pieces and
converting our advantage in the end game
black simply resigns this is a
resignable position uh at this level
because Rook takes D5 is coming that's
two pawns down and the rest of black
spawns are also collapsing so in in an
OTB game I would actually probably
resign here against the G out so it's a
short game but I think it's a really
nice game and it's a good illustration
of how quickly things can go wrong when
one side mishandles like an iqp
structure
um and it also shows you I think that
you don't need to be like super erudite
in these structures to play them well
you just need to exercise common sense
you need to know a couple of key
positional ideas and at that point you
can already successfully fight against
the iqp so there's you know a
misconception that with certain Pawn
structures you have to be Magnus Carlson
in order to play them well well I never
really learned how to fight against iqp
structures formally and yet I think I'm
pretty good against them just by by
using my common sense and by acting
based on all of my experience in these
structures
okay so let's um open up another
instance of the game we've now reached
and we'll start with a quick uh
theoretical overview of this line which
I don't think we faced before so it's a
good idea to uh to to put put out some
background so again here black can play
Queen 65 but this transposes into a
completely different line this is this
is very little to do with uh the the
type of position that we got on the game
and this is more commonly reached uh
after D5 takes takes D4 E6 and Knight F3
and here typically black plays Knight F6
and the move that I recommend here is
Knight to A3 and this we have had I
think already in the speedrun and the
idea of Knight A3 is to meet C takes D4
with this classic idea Knight B5 which
you will find across many different
elephant lines so we've had these types
of lines many times what we haven't
faced is the kind of pure E6 variation
with e takes D5 okay so Bishop B5 check
if I'm not mistaken is the
recommendation of caliphmon in the
alapan Bible that I've been using uh to
to give you some theoretical context on
the lines that we've had
I'm going to double check that this is
in fact their recommendation but I'm 99
sure that it is
just give me a moment so E4 C5 C3 e604
D5 takes takes I'm gonna pull it pull
out
E64 128
yes they also analyze some other
Sidelines that we will leave out of this
analysis
actually no I I um confuse the line
slightly
basically their recommendation is Knight
app3
and only in response to Knight F6 are
they recommending Bishop to B5 checks so
I made this move slightly premature I I
think Bishop B5 is probably a good move
as well
so let me check this with uh yeah Bishop
B5 check is also very common uh the
immediate Bishop E5 check but I think it
might be more accurate to start with
Knight F3
um if black plays Knight F6 we play
Bishop B5 check and we get a very very
similar type of position where typically
black plays Bishop D7
we play Bishop takes D7 check and we get
a very similar type of iqp position and
long story short
if you play whoops just a moment thank
you gemster for the tier one what's up I
was knee good to see you it's been a
while yeah so if you start with Knight
F3 I'm trying to figure out like what
the benefit is of starting with Knight
F3 over starting with this check
and what I'm understanding
is that no actually it often transposes
like for instance if here sorry if after
Ed Knight F3 black plays Knight C6 which
is the main line
um their recommendation is still to play
Bishop B5 so by and large I think these
two moves should transpose into each
other so let's stick to like the move
that I played in the game
um I actually think that Knight C6 is
best
I think that Bishop D7 already gives
white a nice little Edge
so here after Bishop takes D7 Knight D7
Knight F3 Knight F6 the castle black
plays Bishop E7
and these types of positions are pretty
much thankless for black because black
has this isolated Queen pawn and not
much to show for it because with the
light skirt Bishops gone Black's
activity is is at a minimum
and I think the simplest way to play
here is something like I don't know even
Knight to A3 Castle's Knight to C2 is a
popular way of getting the Knight onto a
square where it can jump into D4 and I
would take this position with white any
day but if you turn on the engine it
often gives a very misleading evaluation
of like either total zeros or a
minuscule Edge for white but I think
from what you saw in our game these
types of positions are very very hard
for black to play because black has no
clear plan and no clear way to improve
their position whereas white I think has
many ways to improve like the bishop can
come out the Knight can occupy D4 we can
make some Luft later on the Knight can
jump into F5
and uh I like the look of this a lot for
for white the engine also recommends
um instead of Knight A3 it also
recommends the more simple Bishop E3
and it does give white uh an Ever So
slight Edge which I think is totally
justified so for example Bishop B3
castles
white plays Knight B to D2
of course this position has still
occurred like dozens of times
actually Jasper played this against
David Howell recently Jocelyn played
rookie 8 here David played the top
engine move which was Queen to C2 just
coordinating the Rooks and getting the
queen at a better Square
Jocelyn played Queen C7
David played Rook a to D1 look at how
natural White's moves are and uh
okay there's some other Grandmaster game
where black played Bishop D6
and here the simple Bishop D4 would have
led to a sizable advantage
uh for white because the Knight on F6 is
targeted and if the Knight jumps into E4
white can just sidestep the tension with
Knight to B3 and it's important to
understand that black is always going to
struggle with the long-term weakness on
D5 you should also remember that on D4
you can put either a bishop or a knight
and both pieces are often very very
effective blockaders like traditionally
it's recommended to put a knight on the
Square in front of the iqp but often
putting a bishop on that square is quite
good as well
um so this line isn't like all that
theoretical
um especially if black plays Bishop D7
like this this line is is pretty quiet
so it's not essential that you remember
like the exact move order it's more
important that you kind of remember the
general setup and and where the pieces
belong so Knight C6 is a lot more
theoretical because here black keeps the
light squared Bishops on the board and
the position is quite a bit sharper and
more and more concrete okay so Knight to
C6 Knight to F3 black plays Bishop to D6
which is the main move
still thousands of games in the database
DC Bishop C5 so we're following the main
line
castles
and here yeah so here here is a critical
moment Knight F6 I think is an
inaccuracy and it's a very rare move and
as I indicated during the game I think
black's best bet
uh to fight for equality is actually
Knight to E7 I still think that white is
slightly better here but I think this
placement is much better uh than than on
F6 because this pin is incredibly nasty
and as you saw in the game black was
never really able to fix the problem of
this pin against the Knight
so the main move is Knight G7 here white
typically responds with Knight B to D2
black castles
and uh White of course plays Knight to
B3 uh Black's main move is Bishop B6 but
the newer engines actually prefer to put
the bishop on D6 so that it can exert
some degree of pressure on the H2 pawn
and here the best move is to drop the
bishop back to D3 which does a couple of
things this bishop is very harmoniously
placed it's pressuring H7 and thereby
preventing Bishop G4 which falls for
this comments tactic this isn't a Greek
gift this is just like a simple way to
win a bond because you're picking up the
bishop and again you run into a
situation where black kind of runs out
of helpful moves to make most people
play H6 and white responds with H3 now
Bishop G4 has to be prevented and uh
if black plays Knight to F5 which is the
main move the engine really likes this
idea Bishop C2 followed by Queen to D3
and black and land in big trouble really
really quickly like I'm seeing a bunch
of Grandmaster games where black loses
in a couple of moves here's another Joss
from game and jostim had this with white
against dragubov rookie a queen to D3
and white is already in incredibly good
shape like the engine gives a big
advantage to White because G4 is a major
threat the queen is coming into H7 and
if you can force black to play G6 well
now black has even more weaknesses The
Rook is coming into D1 now the pawn is
very hard to defend I'm I'm just gonna
try to give you a flavor of you know the
kinds of moves that you should be making
here with white
um because certain things have to be
understood like strategically you can
try to memorize a bunch of theory in
this line but I think it's a much better
idea just to kind of learn what the
typical moves are and what you should be
aiming for and there's no better way to
do that than just a kind of open-endedly
explore some of the main moves and to
see what the GM splay etc etc if black
drops back to B6 instead of D6 that I
don't think that significantly changes
White's approach again it's always a
good idea to start with a rookie one
and it's important to understand that
Bishop G4 in and of itself is not a
dangerous move like this pin is not
dangerous when black is exerting it
because black is no easy way to put more
pressure on the Knight so for instance a
good way to fight this is to start with
H3 and now to just continue to trading
off pieces with Bishop E3
and if black takes on E3 and plays
Knight F5 big deal
you just dropped the Rook back to E1 and
if black try is not H4 then you can just
drop the bishop back to E2 and all of
this hinges on one very important
concept which is that if almost all of
the minor Pieces come off the board and
you get a position like this this is a
great illustration of why the iqp is
such a huge liability because when there
are no pieces left on the board black
has a very hard time defending this Pawn
while also taking care of the other
priorities in the position like white
controls the e-file and black can't play
rookie 8 because black loses the pawn
black also can play D4 because white
picks up the pawn with Rook 81 simple
tactics this is just a pen and if black
plays Queen D7 then black again runs
into like a direct attack on the pawn
Rook 81 and then you can play Knight C5
and already hear Black loses the pawn
again because these two threats are
unstoppable at the same time
so
yeah so that that is why
um I think this E6 line
is pretty decent from an engine
perspective but from a human perspective
is incredibly hard to play so in the
gameplays Knight F6 we respond with the
natural Bishop G5 Bishop E6 might be
another inaccuracy but I don't want to
bog down too much uh in all of the
details we go Knight bd2 we play all of
the natural iqp moves put the pot the
Knight on D4 and black plays Bishop to
D7
if I were black I would probably
consider fighting this by playing Rook
to C8 I think this might be a better
uh a better version of what we got in
the game because here
if white does the same thing as in the
game well the bishop is still on E6 so
here I think C5 is a much better version
for for black because this move is no
longer effective due to Queen takes F6
remember that there used to be a bishop
on D7 uh in the game so here black has
to be already very very precise not to
end up in in serious trouble and if
black just like trades a bunch of times
on D4 the situation becomes really
really dire because now we have the
bishop pair we have essentially an
eternal pain against black snipe and
there's just no good way for black to
play here
um of course black can try to continue
trading pieces off but we would be more
than happy I think to reach an end game
like this I think you'd agree with me
that you know this is like an ideal iqp
scenario where black is going to suffer
for the rest of the game with his
miserable pun structure
so no easy way for black to solve his
problems our opponent played Bishop D7
and now transforming the advantage right
first we we try to attack the iqp but
we're not hesitant to transform our
advantage from like positional to more
tactical here our advantage consists of
the fact that we have much more active
pieces and black still has a serious
Pawn weakness on C6 which is being
attacked and already a very very
difficult position for black to play
according to the engine the only way to
keep a decent position was either the
move that our opponent played and we'll
delve into that in a second but there
was another intriguing resource in the
form of Bishop C7 this is almost an
unfindable idea now let's see who can
figure this out what is Black's response
so Bishop takes F6 and just by asking
this question I'm already giving you a
pretty big end so if you're watching on
YouTube you should pause and try to
figure this out how can black tactically
try to solve some of his problems and
this is just about forcing yourself to
look at a move that your brain might be
subconsciously rejecting or consciously
rejected yeah Queen takes F6 and the
idea is to meet Knight D7 with Queen D6
forking the pawn in the night
but the depressing thing
about Black's position is that even if
all of this works out congratulations
amazing white please Queen A4 and white
is still better because the pawn on C6
is still a major weakness and the Knight
is still better than the bishop now this
is the terrifying thing about playing
essentially with permanent weaknesses
it's like no matter how creative you are
how nicely you solve your problems
you're still going to be saddled with
long-term weaknesses and your opponent
is still going to have a very
comfortable game in fact this Pawn
cannot really be defended like but the
engine is giving some like tactical ways
to do it like Rook B8 to attack B2 and
then if B4 then Rook to B6 which is an
awkward move Now The Rook is kind of
stuck off sides
and I would immediately
try to get the open file with Rook 8
that you want I mean who in their right
mind would want a position like this
with black right so
Bishop C7 might have been the most
accurate move our opponent played C5 and
here we enter the kind of more tactical
phase so initially after Bishop F6 GF my
idea excuse me was to play Knight C6
and this is based on an important
tactical concept that you should be very
well aware of which is that the knight
from C6 often aims at E7 and this is a
super common tactic across almost all
openings like you can find an equivalent
of this trick in a million different
types of positions a simple example if
you've watched my stream you know that
this is very prevalent in the jababa
London where if black plays for instance
even Knight C6 in this position already
after Knight B5 black cannot defending
C7 so a lot of people try to give away
the pawn in order to intercept The
Bishop's diagonal and the most common
move here is Knight to E4 and that walks
right into a similar instance of this
type of tactic here the key square is C7
rather than E7 but you get the point
it's the same general principle
now if I remember correctly I even had a
game many years ago where I was able to
use this idea to win a really nice game
let me see if I can dig this up my
opponent was not particularly strong but
knowing this idea helped me make my way
out of the Tactical complications in one
piece I found it so this is back when I
was 1900 this is an old game of mine
from 2006. that's kind of a terrifying
thought and um
okay great so
it's white to play in this position and
my opponent has just
uh well I have just played the move
Queen to E4 in order to Target the C4
pawn and I would I remember not
expecting this move
and kind of sensing that this must be
tactically wrong but I couldn't figure
out exactly why and then it occurred to
me so you play Queen takes C4
black plays Bishop takes C2 and one of
the lectures in in the camp that I just
did was avoiding autopilot moves and
this is I think a great illustration of
that I basically identified five common
situations in which in which autopilot
tends to take over and one of them of
course is when one of your heavy pieces
is threatened either The Rook or the
queen especially newer players just like
instinctually move a piece when it is
threatened and if you go Rook C1 then
blackway's Bishop B3 and black is
completely fine but if you just pause
for a second you should immediately spot
the correct idea which is this move
Knight C5 and now you open up an attack
on the bishop the end against the queen
and of course black can't take because
he drops the queen so I was expecting
our my opponent to play Queen to D7 here
and I had cooked up the Desperado sack
Knight takes C7 and queen takes C2 item
up a pawn but to my great surprise black
finds a very creative defensive resource
Bishop to B3
and it took me a second to figure out
how to make my way out of this white
Supply and obviously you know what the
theme is and so you know that the move
is Queen takes C6 the only move that
gives white a big advantage and my
opponent declines the quote unquote
sacrifice but the idea is that if the
queen sack is accepted white emerges
with two extra Pawns in a completely
winning end game and my opponent went
away I took the pawn anyway I managed to
trade queens and I ended up winning the
game so I didn't calculate it all in
advance but this kind of comes all of a
sudden still anytime you're accessing
the E7 Pawn remember that these like
Queen deflection tricks are pretty
common across many different types of
positions and as a general takeaway
remember that like tactical vision is
based not just on pattern recognition
and on like solving
a bunch of puzzles but also on like
consciously keeping track of of tactical
patterns that you come across and I'm
annoyed that this isn't talked about
more frequently like it's not all about
pattern recognition and training your
brain to see stuff it's also about
consciously being aware like oh my
Knight's on C6 okay there's a weak Pawn
on Z5 there's a weak King on G8 well
what patterns am I aware that exploit
all of these things the problem though
is after Knight takes C6 black has a
very Advanced idea black can drop the
queen over to E8 and this seems to give
the pawn away without a fight but
suddenly have to Rook C8 the Knight is
trapped a night literally is nowhere to
go it's a rare situation where the king
is weak white species are more active
but somehow black is able to pick up the
minor piece now let's say that you
blundered the Knight let's say you went
for this line and you're staring at this
position you're like I'm screwed what
would you do here with white to give
yourself the most practical chances
another good exercise let's say you
blundered how do you respond to this
Ponder what's the only way to get
practical chances for white
so I think most people are probably
thinking rookie won but rookie one is a
really bad move because it it actually
helps your opponent do what he wants to
do anyway like yeah you got your Rook to
an open file but now you just have a
piece for a punt if you've plundered a
piece like this your first question
should be can I give the piece away for
a maximum amount of material and the
best move here the only move I think
that gives white serious chances is
Knight takes A7 because at the very
least you've created a three-on-one on
the queen side and then I would just
like push A4 I would try to prepare
myself for a potential end game by
pushing this Pawn up as far as it'll go
and trying to keep this bishop out of
commission so
just you know very important takeaway
like when you blunder a piece like this
or when your opponent traps a piece you
shouldn't immediately panic
when you should always begin by asking
whether this piece can be given up for a
maximum amount of material okay
so anyways this is what I had to avoid
and this is why we took on D7 and
dropped our Knight back to C2 and kind
of keep a relatively small but very
stable Advantage so I actually think
Rook ft8 is a very serious mistake and
this is a this is an advanced mistake
right this is like a 2100 level mistake
if you're 900 and you're watching this I
think this will be a little harder to
understand but broadly speaking this
move is a mistake because it leaves the
king without any Defenders and it makes
the move Queen F3 incredibly strong
there's another hidden reason which is
that the Rook on A8 is now in the
crosshairs of White's Queen and there's
no way to like see this when you play
Rook fd8 but in my opinion it would be
much more natural for black to put the
other Rook on d8 and this would avoid a
lot of the problems that black came
across in the game
so here we would still play Queen F3 and
if we follow the line from the game like
Queen D6 Knight E3 it's still very bad
for black that's true
but probably in this position Black's
best and maybe last chance would be to
generate counter play with C4 I really
think that black had to try to rely on
the only asset in his position that
passed Pawn to potentially pass spawn
and try to shove it down as far as it'll
go okay that yeah
um could have said that differently here
we would have probably played Rook a to
D1 and I don't know Queen to D5 is the
engine move so yeah like black has to
defend like an engine basically to get
practical chances
the engine by the way gives uh the chest
dot comments it gives Rook F to E1 which
is a slightly weird move because it
allows D3
but the point is the one that I made to
during the game which is that I think
when a newer player looks at a position
like this they're automatically super
afraid of the spot like oh this Pawn is
going to promote and D2 is really scary
in fact D2 is a huge mistake because
this Pawn is a lot more of a weakness
than a strength and I think past Pawns
in the middle game is a concept which is
not talked about enough because it's a
concept Associated primarily with the
end game in the middle game like past
pawns can often be very very
double-sided in this case it's a big
weakness because it's only a matter of
time before white surrounds this Pawn in
fact after a move like Rook F to E8 well
Rook fva we have Knight G4 and the F6
Pawn is indefensible
but a very instructive line is what
white does after Queen to E6 white has a
really sexy way here of winning the pawn
on Z2 and it's a retreating move that's
hard to find this is like a Grand Master
Level move I think a lot of you might be
saying oh it's Queen E2 but if you play
Queen E2 you walk into C4
and again this is super Advanced like
tactical complications but the bottom
line is that the Knight is now pinned
instead you should consider Knight F1
of course you would want to go Knight C4
but that square is protected so instead
you play Knight F1 good job and black
has no way to defend E2 and largely it's
because this bishop is so out of the
game
black can still play C4 but then we take
on D2 and black as little to none
compensation to no compensation for the
for the extra point
so okay so Rook Ada would have been a
better option when black put the other
Rook on d8 I still think black should
have played T4 here so I think the
decisive mistake is actually Queen to D6
because once this Knight gets to E3 the
combined threats against Black's King
couples with all of the threats against
this spawn cause Black's position to
just completely fall apart so I think
black's last chance would have been to
play D4 here and prevent this knight
from easily reaching E3
white is a variety of things that that
they can do I probably would have gone
Rook a to D1 and to be honest like I
didn't the engine moved here which is
Queen D5 didn't even occur to me because
we can just take F6 and white is still
much better
but at least you know black maintains
some semblance of counter player maybe
Queen E6 but then we go Rook out V1 and
continue chasing the queen around
so this is just uh this is a bad
position for black
and and these positions are almost
impossible to play for players like
under you know 2400. uh if in that line
Queen takes A2 select Rook ad1 Queen D5
Queen F6 Queen A2 gets mated like we go
Rook T3
and I mentioned this idea during the
game like the The Rook lifts can come
all of a sudden because you're not
thinking about it you're thinking about
what's going on in the center but
suddenly Rook G3 is completely
Unstoppable maybe black can try this but
then F4 is super powerful just
intercepting the bishop and preparing
Rook to G3 so the bottom line is that
you have to keep an eye on everything at
the same time you can't get fixated on
one particular aspect of your advantage
and at all times you have to keep in
track keep track of why you're better
like what are the advantages that you
possess here it's primarily divided into
I would say three things the first is
and most obvious is like the weakness of
Black's Pawn structure but attendant to
that is also the great weakness of the
king the second is the pressure that we
exert on Black's Center primarily the D5
pawn and then the third aspect of our
advantage is the superior Knight when
compared to the bishop because the
Knight is very very good at accessing a
lot of these weak squares
so a good example of transforming the
advantage the plot is no longer isolated
but it's still incredibly weak and just
to be clear the reason D4 well it
doesn't lose immediately but Knight F5
is kind of a hammer blow because if
black plays Queen to D5 then he gets
four if black plays Queen to E5 then the
win is very straightforward we can just
like give a check and win the queen and
so in this position black would have had
to drop the queen back to f8
and here again the best engine move is
super instructive what do you think the
top engine move is here it's a very
patient move and it's a move that shows
that you understand like the scope of
your advantage and you understand the
importance of being very patient
yeah Rook fe1 is great even better is to
play Rook a to D1
because this move exerts pressure on D4
but what else is it to well what it does
is it actually prepares a rook lift so
here for example black can't even defend
the F6 Pawn but even if black tries to
sack The Exchange will you ignore it and
go Rook D3 Rook H3 and win the game
because black is totally paralyzed so
when you're in a situation where you
sense that the win is close don't try to
win it all in three moves like don't try
to force anything remember that in some
positions you can just make these slower
moves and because your opponent has no
easy way to fix the problems in their
position you can afford uh to play with
this kind of tempo and and this is stuff
that you kind of gain by Seal and by
experience you can learn it but moves
like Rook 81 are moves that you make on
the basis of like a lot of experience
converting these types of positions so
anyways or rookie one also would have
been very strong black plays Bishop C7
we defend against mate we bring our Rook
into D1 and we win the game
e is the line 90 for cdcd and here
actually another very instructive moment
the majority of people including myself
would probably play Rook takes D4 this
is what I mentioned in the game but if
you analyze with the engine like this
position is a lot less convincing then
the one after White's best move the
issue is that if you continue gobbling
pawns you've suddenly given black like a
fair measure of activity and this is
often what happens when you go Pawn
grabbing like this is a trade-off when
you take a bunch of Pawns you're
spending Tempe and you're often opening
up the position which is giving your
opponent's pieces a certain degree of
activity now sometimes that's a normal
part of the winning process like
sometimes you have to give your opponent
a fair measure of activity but here I
think it's actually quite hard to keep
Black's initiative tamped down if you
drop back to A6 suddenly the root comes
into D2 and suddenly you know the Knight
can't move from E3 because of the
discovery so much better than Rook takes
D4 and much more patient would have been
actually Knight to F5 great example of
seeing a tactic but considering the
other candidate moves and when you start
looking at Knight F5 you realize why
it's so much stronger well first of all
you have this queen G4 Queen G7 threat
so Black's response is forced now again
you can take on Z4 but even better is to
just accumulate the pressure with the
Rook F1 because this pod is not going
anywhere you can take the spot
essentially whenever you want so after
black plays Bishop B5 now is a great
time to play Rook takes D4 because you
can't take with the bishop you
definitely can't take with a rook
because here you just get checkmated
and White's next move is just going to
be Rook H4 and queen H5 with checkmate
now are you expected to see this
particular idea when you play Knight F5
no you're just making natural moves and
in the course of making those natural
moves these kinds of wins arrive at your
doorstep by the way Queen City 5 Rook to
EA check very important trick that you
should be aware of
this wins the queen via deflection you
see this a lot in puzzle Rush
black has no good squares for the Queen
the game is over
if the queen goes to the other side of
the board you can still play Rook takes
before because again this gets
checkmated
Rook T8 and queen 68 is a very pretty
pattern rokid is a background paint
um so that would have been the most
efficient response to D4 instead our
opponent gives away F6 and then gives
away D5 and resigns I would have played
some more moves but obviously like after
King h8 Rook takes D5 at this point the
simplest approach to winning would just
be to trade the Queens off the board and
you can't really blame black for not
wanting to play this position down two
pawns with like more pawns falling along
the way
um so the actual end of the game was
pretty anticlimactic but there was a lot
that was contained sort of behind the
scenes so a couple of takeaways from
this short simple but instructive game
first of all this line against the
elephant is often tempting for people
because the engine really likes it but
in my opinion it's a pretty inferior
version of the iqp structure in a very
very difficult position for black to
play like you need to know a ton of
theory with black you need to know all
the right setups in order to play this
successfully I've tried playing this
with black against the elephant and I've
never enjoyed it
um so then of course we talked at length
about where the pieces kind of belong
when you're fighting the isolated Queen
Pawn the most important rule is to
control the score in front of the pawn
to develop your pieces actively and to
understand that you're not fixated on
the iqp there's other stuff in the
position that you can also do
and that was the theme of Bishop takes
C6 which is a classic example of
transforming your advantage so don't be
afraid to give away one strength of your
position in return for another that is a
normal part of the conversion process so
here we black no longer has the iqp
instead of black as the hanging Bond
structure but in return we get massive
piece activity and tremendous tactical
potential thank you the brontologist
that is the sort of
basic premise of this game here we
dodged narrowly dodged a bullet
um with with Knight dc6 still a good
tactical pattern to keep in mind
but we were not afraid just to make a
retreating move night back to C2 in
order to involve it around on E3 and
then a classic example of fighting and
exploiting multiple things at once right
not just the D5 font which is once again
now Black's major weakness but also the
weak Pawn on F6 and the weak King and by
combining pressure against all of these
things we were able to cause Black's
position to collapse really really
quickly and that is about it any
questions
yeah iqp stands for isolated Queen spawn
which is a very common structure that
occurs across many many different types
of openings the elephant is just one of
them and the iqp and the Elephant occurs
across many different lines like the E6
variation is not the only one in which
black gets the iqp most commonly the iqp
is reached by uh the kind of the main
line so like but but here it's wide who
is the iqp like at any point in the main
line black can play the move C takes D4
and now it's white who has the iqp and
it's actually quite unique for an
opening to feature two different lines
where like both sides essentially
experience the isolated Queen pawn and
I'm sure that we're going to face this
particular line from the white side as
well so I'll have a chance to to talk
about playing with the iqp as well here
we talked about playing against it so
ikp is not like a known concept because
the isolated King Pawn uh is is not
common across open so of course like you
could have an isolated kingspawn but
that's not like a you know commonly
talked about structure if that makes
sense
okay so one question by re1 what about
blocking with the rook and make the
queen move at the end there I'm not sure
what you're referring to
oh blocking with the Rook here well then
we just play Queen takes D5 like if
you're talking about blocking with the
Rook here then we just play Queen 60 we
could even play Knight 65 if you want to
be fancy you can even do this
I would caution against this type of
stuff unless you're a professional but
yeah this is also a possible way of
winning a second pot okay
so the elephant prevails once again we
can see that it holds up at a very high
level
and I will continue fighting that
misconception until the end of my days
hope you enjoyed the game it was a
simple one I'm still kind of recovering
my energy after the campites on and so
sorry if I was a little bit lethargic
and I'll see you guys later thanks
everybody for hanging out I hope you
enjoyed the speed run and the Blitz
foreign
[Music]